va-t-on vers une fronde généralisée des
policiers français après le placement
des tensions provisoires d'un de leurs
collègues vendredi dernier plus de 250
policiers marseillais se sont mis en
arrêt maladie ce week-end signe de
protestation contre cette incarcération
au total ce sont entre 500 et 600 agents
de la ville qui pourraient manquer à
l'appel en ce début de semaine si l'on
prend en compte le délai dont il dispose
pour poster leur arrêt de travail en
signe de soutien à leurs collègues
incarcéré une boucle sur la messagerie
télégram a été créée plus de 2500
policiers de toute la France l'avait
rejointe ce week-end cette action
spontanée hors champs syndicale démontre
que les organisations professionnelles
n'ont pas vraiment la main dans cette
affaire même si plusieurs leaders
syndicaux se sont émus de cette
incarcération certains dénoncent la
marque d'une présomption de culpabilité
réservée aux policiers d'autres y voit
le symbole d'un ras-le-bol général à la
sortie d'un épisode des meute ultra
violent sur telegram plusieurs messages
vont en ce sens un policier écrit il ne
faut plus que ce qui est arrivé fin juin
début juillet se reproduit parle parce
que j'y étais c'était une guérilla dès
lors de casseurs pilleurs un truc de fou
je n'avais jamais vécu ça en 25 ans de
métier un autre dénonce ça fait 25 ans
que tous les gouvernements nous prennent
pour des serpillières sous-payés
usés jusqu'à la corde burn out suicide
et démission en masse lynché par les
médias lâché par la justice et même
traiter d'un culte par notre propre
ministre le policier placé en détention
avait été mise en examen comme trois de
ses collègues dans la nuit du 20 au 21
juillet pour violence en réunion par
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique avec
usage ou menace d'une arme ayant
entraîné une incapacité totale de
travail supérieur à 8 jours les quatre
policiers de la BAC sont soupçonnés
d'avoir passé à tabac Eddy un homme de
21 ans en marge des émeutes dans la nuit
du 1er au 2 juillet interrogé par la
Provence sur son lit d'hôpital il
affirme qu'il sortait de son service
dans l'hôtel restauration au moment des
faits et n'avait pas l'intention de
participer aux émeutes après cette
incarcération d'autres soutien ont fait
polémique le directeur général de la
police nationale Frédéric vaut a
notamment déclaré qu'avant un éventuel
procès un policier n'a pas sa place en
prison même s'il a pu commettre des
fautes ou des erreurs graves dans le
cadre de son travail des propos que le
préfet de police de Paris Laurent a dit
partager gravissime dérive inquiétantes
et queran à gauche l'ensemble de la nups
s'est mobilisée sur Twitter pour
condamner ses soutiens de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à Olivier Faure en passant par
Eric Coquerel en déplacement à Nouméa en
Nouvelle-Calédonie Emmanuel Macron quant
à lui n'a pas souhaité commenter les
propos de Frédéric veau interroger lors
des journaux télévisés de 13 heures de
TF1 et de France 2 le président de la
République a longuement rendu hommage
aux policiers mobilisés lors des émeutes
avant de finalement rappeler que
personne n'était au-dessus du cadre
républicain
[Musique]